[Musique] étrangère
depuis que je suis enfant
la saison
donc je pars poursuivre mes
rêves
Je vais être le roi des Pirates
tout ce dont j'ai besoin c'est d'un équipage loyal
et je pense
qu'ensemble nous formons une assez bonne équipe
nous  "Nous nous dirigeons vers Grand Line
[Musique] une
étendue d'océan dangereuse avec des îles plus grandes
et de plus gros pirates,
je ne travaille pas pour vous, je
ressens un peu de tension au sein
de l'équipage
[Musique]
Je sais que nous"  Nous avons le meilleur de chacun,
revenons
tous les grands combattants annoncent leurs
mouvements de finition
non, ils ne sont pas
étrangers
[Musique]